- Okay, welcome everyone
and thank you for joining us this evening
for our presentation and
discussion of an academic paper,
"Safe Seats and Female
(Under)Representation
in the U.S. Congress" by Akhil Rajan,
Alexander Kustov,
Maikol Cerda,
Frances Rosenbluth
and Ian Shapiro.
This event is part of a series of events
that ISPS, the Institution
for Social and Policy Studies,
is holding this year called ISPS Democracy
and these events bring
together experts from Yale
and beyond to shed light
on key questions concerning
American politics,
governance and democracy.
The next event in this
ISPS Democracy series
will be Tuesday, April 13th, at 4:00 pm,
our regular time is seven,
but this is at 4:00 pm,
rethinking political representation
where we'll have a number of experts
on novel ways of holding elections
and engaging in legislative deliberations.
Before I continue on to
discuss tonight's event
I wanna make sure to thank
the organizers of this event
Pam Greene, Pam Lamonaca,
Tory Bilski and Limor Peer.
So here are the logistics
for tonight's event,
we'll have the authors present their work
for about 20 minutes.
After that, we'll have
about 10 minutes each
from two discussants
that we've invited to this event
and then after the discussants conclude,
the panelists will have an opportunity,
the paper presenters will
have an opportunity to respond
to the discussants after
which we'll have some time
for questions from the audience
and here's how the audience
will ask questions.
Please save your questions till
after the discussants have
concluded their remarks
and use the raise hand button
on the bottom of the Zoom screen
to indicate that you have a
question you'd like to ask.
Also, if you'd like,
you can send questions
to the panelists via the chat
and if you do that through the chat,
keep the questions reasonably concise
so that they can be read
and understood easily.
And I just also wanna indicate
that tonight's event is being recorded.
With that, let me introduce
tonight's participants.
First, the presenting authors,
Ian Shapiro is the Sterling Professor
of political science at Yale University.
He served as chair of political science
from 1999,
no that's, I think that's,
I bet longer than that.
You served as chair of political science
for a number of years,
very successful and wonderful years,
and you also served as the director
of the MacMillan Center for
International and Area Studies
from 2004 to 2019
and as a fellow of the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences,
the American Philosophical Society
and the National Academy
of Social Insurance.
He has written widely and
influentially on democracy,
justice and methods of social inquiry.
His current research
concerns the relations
between democracy and the
distribution of income.
Our second presenter is Akhil Rajan.
Rajan is a senior at Yale College,
enrolled in the simultaneous
B.A./M.A. program
in political science
and the multidisciplinary
academic program in human rights.
Rajan studies the intersection
of political behavior and populism,
as well as policy responses
to the threat of democratic backsliding.
He was an ISPS Director's Fellow in 2019
and a Dahl Scholar during
the 2018/2019 academic year.
Alex Kustov is a postdoctoral associate
in the Leitner Program on
Effective Democratic Governance
in the Jackson Institute
for Global Affairs.
His research focuses on
public policy responses
to immigration and ethnic
conflict in high-income countries.
He received his PhD in politics
and social policy from Princeton
and will be an assistant
professor of political science
and political administration
at the University
of North Carolina at Charlotte
starting in August of 2021.
And I do want to recognize
the non-presenting authors
who are not gonna be making
a presentation tonight
but contributed very much to the paper.
Frances Rosenbluth is
the Damon Wells Professor
of Political Science at Yale,
a fellow of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences,
a leading scholar of
comparative political economy
and a beloved colleague.
Her current work focuses on
the electoral microfoundations
of different forms of
capitalism on the politics
of gender inequality.
She published many articles on,
on a variety of subjects,
some recently on the
political economy of gender
and on women's
under-representation in politics.
Her recent book with Ian Shapiro was
"Responsible Parties: Saving
Democracy from Itself",
published in 2018.
And then the fifth author on
this paper is Maikol Cerda.
Cerda is a postdoctoral
fellow at Yale University,
received a PhD in economics from NYU.
Cerda's research interests
include industrial organization,
competition policy, statistical learning
and applied microeconomics.
So those are our paper authors.
I'll finally conclude
with our two discussants.
Our two discussants are Frances Lee
and Jonathan Rodden.
Frances Lee is a professor of
politics and public affairs,
an associate chair at the
department of politics,
Princeton University,
fellow of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences.
Her research centers on American politics
with a special focus on
congressional politics,
national policymaking,
party politics and representation.
She is the editor of the
Cambridge Elements series
in American politics
and her recent book "Insecure Majorities:
Congress and the Perpetual
Campaign" explore the rise
of congressional party
conflict showing how shifts
in competitiveness had a
profound impact on how Democrats
and Republicans interact
in the policy sphere.
Lee is the recipient of the highest prizes
for her scholarship
from the American Political
Science Association.
She received the Richard Fenno Prize
for the best book in legislative studies
and she is a two-time recipient
of the D.B. Hardeman Prize,
presented by the Lyndon
Baines Johnson Foundation
for the best book on the US Congress
from the fields of biography, history,
journalism and political science.
I'll just say that there's
no one who is a finer scholar
of the contemporary
Congress who is actively
writing now than, than Professor Lee.
It is a true delight to
have her with us tonight.
Jonathan Rodden.
Jonathan Rodden is a professor
of political science
at Stanford University.
He is a senior fellow at
the Hoover Institution
and the Stanford Institute
for Economic Policy Research.
He is the founder and director
of the Stanford Spatial
Social Science Lab,
the center for research and teaching,
focusing on geospatial analysis
in the social sciences.
That's a subject that Jonathan is
among the world's experts on that subject,
the geospatial analysis of politics.
Rodden's interests lie at the intersection
of political science, public
economics and geography.
He's the author of a number of books
including a 2007 book,
"Hamilton's Paradox:
The Promise and Peril
of Fiscal Federalism"
and for which he was the recipient
of the Gregory Luebbert
Prize for the best book
in comparative politics in that year.
Again, thank you, Jonathan.
Welcome back to Yale.
Jonathan was a student
here a number of years ago
and it's wonderful to have you back.
So with that, let me turn it over to,
I believe Ian is gonna go first.
Let me turn it over to Ian.
After Ian
and Akhil and Alexander are done,
we'll go immediately to
Frances and then Jonathan,
the panelists will have their discussion
and then we'll go immediately
to question and answer.
Thank you all for joining us this evening.
- Thank you, Alan
and thank you, Pam and more for
doing all the heavy lifting
to get us here this evening.
Thank you also to Frances
and Jonathan for agreeing to do this.
We very much appreciate it
and we look forward to your comments.
I'm just gonna talk briefly
about the project out
of which this paper came
and then I will turn it
over to Akhil and then Alex
to present different parts
of this particular paper.
As Alan mentioned, this work comes out
of the Leitner Program
on Effective Democratic
Governance at the Jackson Institute
that Frances Rosenbluth and I run,
and we should take note
that all of the research
here is paid for by Jim
Leitner through that program
and we wouldn't be able to
do it but for his generosity.
The remit
of the
program is to study
which types of democracy
are most conducive
to good public policy and
within democratic systems
as we find them as we've
inherited them if you like,
what institutional
reforms would would make
them operate more effectively
and produce better public policy?
This is the work that,
this one stream of this work
that Alex, Michael, Akhil
and I have been doing with Frances
that has produced several papers
and is producing several more
and they were all focused in one way
or another on the
organization and governance
of political parties
and how that affects political outcomes.
In the US, this has led us
to devote a lot of attention
to the study of the
operation and evolution
of the primary system,
of course at the presidential level
that's only been since the
1970s when they became important
but at the congressional
levels, as everyone knows,
primaries have been around
since the progressive era,
so it's not just primaries
that have gotten our attention
but rather the interaction
between primaries and safe seats
and we have built up a
data set on the growth
of safe seats that they're going
to be talking about tonight.
And so we've been looking
at that more generally
as it relates to things
like party discipline
and the capacity to produce
policies that are good
for the economy in the longer run.
This particular research
comes at the intersection
between that and Frances
Rosenbluth's ongoing interest
in female representation
and so that was bringing those two streams
of interests together
that resulted in the paper
that we're gonna talk about tonight.
So with that, let me
turn it over to Akhil.
The floor is yours.
- Great.
Thank you, Professor Shapiro.
Let me just load those slides up.
So thanks everyone for coming out today.
So as professor Shapiro was saying,
we're gonna be looking
at the problem of the rise of safe seats
in the United States
and how that's gonna help us understand
this growing phenomenon of
women's under-representation
in the US Congress.
But before I dive into that,
I wanna start with a brief roadmap
for where we're gonna go
in our presentation today.
So I'm going to start
by talking a little bit
about the problem and the
conventional explanations
for this gender gap between the parties
in women's representation in Congress,
then we're gonna shift over to talking
about our story contrary
to these conventional
explanations that safe seats are to blame.
Alex is gonna hop on and talk
about the connection between
safe seats and extremism
and then we're gonna loop back
to this question of safe seats
and women's representation.
We'll have a little bit of a discussion
and questions for
further scholarly inquiry
and then we're excited
to get some feedback
from our wonderful discussants here today.
So to just ground us in
the idea of the problem,
it's well-documented
across political science
and also across popular media
that women are dramatically
underrepresented
in the United States Congress.
But what is sometimes less
appreciated is the trajectory
of how things are changing.
Within the Democratic Party,
we are seeing substantial
gains for women politicians
especially in the House
of Representatives,
slightly less fewer gains in the Senate,
but among Republicans,
we're actually seeing
very anemic growth
and one way to look at that is
in the partisan gap in women
members of the US House.
So if you go all the way back
to 1985 to the 99th Congress,
there was no partisan gap,
there was an equal
number of women and men,
sorry, of women elected
from the Democratic
and the Republican Party,
versus today you see a huge gap of upwards
of 60 seats between the two of them,
most famously we saw this in 2018
which was heralded as
the year of the woman
for the record number of women
were elected to Congress,
but actually, if you
look closer at the data,
a record number of Republican
women lost their seats.
So when we're talking
about this gender gap
in representation,
it's also important that we look
at the growing partisan gender
gap as one of the sources.
Now, the conventional
explanations are twofold.
First, some point to
the partisan gender gap
among the electorate.
It's true that we see these
same patterns reflected
in the electorate.
Women are more likely
to vote for Democrats
and men, on average, are more likely
to vote for Republicans.
And the second explanation is, of course,
the under-supply of
Republican women candidates,
which is somewhat related
to that first explanation.
But there are a couple of reasons why
we think both of those explanations
fall a little bit short.
So the first, looking at the
partisan gap in the electorate,
we see that it's always been high.
Dating back to 1980, you had
almost a nine point gender gap
and today, if you're looking at exit polls
in presidential voting,
which as unreliable they are,
offer us probably the best metric
for intertemporal comparison,
that gap has risen to about 11 points.
So it is true that you could argue
that the gender gap has gotten wider,
but perhaps not as significantly
among the electorate as it has
among elected representatives
in Congress.
So to put that more concretely,
the gender gap since 1985
in Congress has risen
from zero to 60 seats between the parties,
among the electorate, it's increased
by a maximum of about four points.
And the other thing to
note is that in contrast
to our last slide which
showed this steady rise
in the gender gap between the Democrats
and Republicans in Congress,
the swings in the electorate haven't had
either the drama in terms of
magnitude, but also direction.
We saw times in this period
between 1980 and 2016
when most scholarly accounts would agree,
actually the gender gap among
the electorate got less severe
and yet the gender gap among members
of Congress has increased steadily.
The second explanation would
be that undersupply story,
that there just aren't enough
women Republicans running
but there are two problems with this.
The first is that an undersupply story
itself is arguably endogenous.
You can't construct a
complete causal story
and the reason is something
we'll get to later
in our presentation,
which is if you say that
there are voter biases
against women candidates
and women candidates don't run
because they're aware
of those voter biases,
can you really say the undersupply is
the complete causal story
for why we have women's
under-representation?
We think that that's a flawed argument
or, at best, an incomplete argument.
And then the other reason
that we are skeptical
of this conventional account is
that it's unclear why this problem
of undersupply should have
increased in magnitude
over the past years,
despite the fact that candidate access
to the ballot has been greatly
democratized over the years.
We see more candidates running
and therefore we should see
arguably less in gender barriers
to candidacy as well.
So for those two reasons, we
enter this project skeptical
of the conventional narratives
around the gender gap within Congress.
So our story is focused
on the electoral institutions
that create these
gender biases in representation
and specifically safe seats.
So we see the partisan gap
as a function of declining
electoral competition.
We provide evidence and
we hypothesize initially
that women candidates
are gonna outperform men
in Democratic safe seats,
but crucially they're
gonna underperform men
in Republican safe seats
and we'd say that because of that,
the recent rise in safe seats,
the exponential growth of safe seats,
among both parties can help
contribute to that explanation
of why this partisan gap
has grown over the period
of time we're studying.
The prior literature really builds
to that hypothesis in three separate ways.
So the first is there's a wide body
of evidence about how women
candidates are stereotyped
as more liberal than men
that goes back into the 1990s
but with more recent additions,
like Sanbonmatsu and Dolan in 2009,
seems to be a pattern that
is still well and alive.
We also see some evidence
in the literature
that safe seats are intensifying
the importance of primaries
and thereby extremism
because the primary mode
of competition is no longer
this general election
where politicians are supposedly competing
for the median voter
but rather the primary
where they're competing
for the median primary voter.
And we're also gonna present
some evidence in addition
to this prior literature for
why we think that effect holds
and why we think these safe
seats encourage extremisms.
And then the final thing
we're going to talk
about is a combination
of both literature on how
safe seats have been on the
rise over the past decade
and also a new data set we've put together
to document precisely
how much they have risen
over this period of time.
So with that, I'm gonna
turn it over to Alex
to preview our arguments about
safe seats and extremism.
- Yeah.
Hi, everyone.
Thanks, Akhil.
So I just wanted to kind of elaborate
on these last two points that you had
about the importance of safe
seats and their increase
and this is a part of our
broader project on, you know,
the role of electoral
competition and party governance
but I think it's very
relevant to today's paper.
Also I just wanted to spend
a few minutes on that.
So first, you know, I
just wanna kind of present
this very kind of basic graph which plots,
you know, the ideology of
a certain representative
alongside their, you know,
with the partisan composition
of their constituency
and, you know, this graph basically shows
that in places with more Democrats,
you have more liberal representatives
in terms of the voting patterns
and in places with more, you know,
Republicans you have representatives
who vote more conservatively,
quote, unquote,
as measured by DW-NOMINATE score
which of course we know
has certain limitations
but we can also show that this picture is
pretty much staying the same
regardless of what measure you use,
whether it's CF scores,
DW-NOMINATE score or some
kind of interest group scores.
And, you know, oftentimes
when you see this picture,
I think the first thing that pops up
which we fully knowledge
is that, you know,
if you take a given district
with a certain composition,
let's say a district with, you know,
more or less even part of the composition
of Democrats or Republicans, you know,
depending on whether it's represented
by a Democrat or Republican,
the DW-NOMINATE score or the
ideology of representative
and their awarding patterns
can be very different
and it's true but what
we also see here is that,
you know, it is also true that depending
on the partisan composition
of a certain district,
whether it's a safe Democratic seats
or a safe Republican seats,
the voting patterns
of representatives are
very much different.
And, you know,
we don't wanna kind of
have any normative ideas
about whether it's bad or good,
but I think it's also important
to have some kind of comparative glance
and think about whether it's
truly need to be the case.
So for instance, if we can
consider not just the US
but kinda other, you know,
two-party democracies,
then we can also see that
actually it doesn't have
to be the case that, you know,
a place with a more, you know,
like a safer constituency
for a certain party,
it has to have a very
different voting patterns.
You know, if the party has
control or candidates and,
you know, kinda
institutions are different.
So why is it the case that, you know,
safer seats produce
more extreme candidates?
So there are three main reasons for that,
that, you know, kind
of we wanna emphasize.
You know, first and most
obviously is that, you know,
obviously if you have a
very safe Democratic seats
that probably it is the case
that on average, you know,
it has more extreme Democratic voters
and so, you know,
the representatives are gonna
responding to this more extreme voters.
An issue more kind of alluded this story
than you might think
and for instance, you know,
Jonathan Rodden were discussing
has a very good evidence on that,
that you can easily imagine
that you can have a
majority Democratic district
that most have voted for Biden,
but it's actually not
that extreme in terms
of its voting population,
but it's still the case
that on average, of course,
you know, they have safe
Democratic seats is gonna be
more extreme in terms
of the borders there.
It's also the case that when you have
a safe democratic seats,
in terms of campaign finance,
there are gonna be more demand
for outside money there.
And it is interesting because sometimes
we don't really kind of consider
that you have a safe
Democratic seats is actually
it still requires a lot of, you know,
funds and money to actually
compete in those places
but it is the case that in those
places we see more reliance
on interest groups and
kind of outside money
in terms of, you know,
out of district spending as well.
But most importantly
for our purposes here,
I would like to emphasize
that in safer seats,
whether it's Democratic
or Republican seats,
we have more vulnerability
to more primary challengers
and also more extreme primary challenges.
And I just wanted to show you
like a few graphs that can be relevant
to what we're talking about here.
Right, so first, if we
just consider the universe
of primary challengers
and, you know, the incumbents who have
to face these challenges,
we see that the primary
challengers are usually
more ideologically extreme
as measured as CF scores
here which is based on
campaign finance networks.
So what we see here is
basically when we look
at challengers that are blue dots here,
they on average, you know,
a higher in this matlibplots
which means they have kind of more
conservative, quote,
unquote, ideology compared
to the incumbents in those districts.
And we see that kind of
opposite picture for that
for Democrats.
So we see that if we look
at Democratic challengers
in safer seats,
or more generally they're
usually more extreme
than those that are incumbents.
But most importantly, for our purposes,
we also see that if you're in a safe seat,
which is measured by this
Cook Partisan Voting Index
that Akhil is gonna talk a
little bit more about later,
we see that, you know, representatives
and incumbents in those
districts are more likely
to face primary challenge
and actually even more so the
case in Republican safe seats.
And now they're kind of part of the puzzle
which is important for our story here
which is part of the paper is
that we see a gradual decline
in electoral competition
for US House across here.
So, you know, obviously
we have redistricting,
we have sort of like
oscillations here and there
but in general, the trend is on decline,
so this is just, you know,
seat safety based on, you
know, basic margin of victory
but we can also see the
same story when it comes
to kinda more ex-ante measure
of competitiveness based
on this Cook Partisan Voting Index
where we see that there is a decline,
has been in decline of
marginal seats since 1992,
since, you know, when we had the data
and we also have a slight
increase of Democratic
and especially Republican safe seats.
Okay, Akhil, I think I
can go back to you now.
Thank you.
- Sorry.
So yeah, so connecting
the story of safe seats
and extremism back to our original theory,
what we posit then is that
Democratic women should perform
better in safe Democratic seats,
whereas Republican women should
be dramatically outperformed
in safe Republican seats.
And so to really study this
problem in a more rigorous way,
we combine two existing data sets
and opine some metrics
that we think are lacking in them so far.
So first we start with
Adam Bonica's 2019 database
of ideology and money in elections
to identify all of the
candidates who have filed
with the FEC to run for Congress
and some basic demographic
information of them,
both on the campaign finance side
and also personal demographic
information like gender
and the nice thing about
this data set is we also
get a sense of their
actual electoral fortunes.
Then we take a dataset
from Cook Political to look
at the cook PVI,
which is a measure of
the partisan composition
on electoral competitiveness
of house districts.
So the way to think of a Cook
PVI is as a relative measure.
So if we say a district
is Democrat plus five,
that means in a year where Democrats
and Republicans tied
overall across the nation,
we would expect that district
to have voted five points more
for the Democratic candidate
than the Republican candidate.
And the first thing that we try to do is
just a pretty basic descriptive task.
So right here what we see is
the modeled win probability
for the Democratic and
Republican candidates
by their seat safety and by gender.
So just to walk us through
this really quickly,
the top panels are all Republicans
and what we see here is that,
looking at the leftmost panel
which is the overall win rate,
for the vast majority of seats,
you see almost gender parody
in that the probability that a woman
or a man who enters the
primary election has virtually
the same probability of
winning the election.
Now I should caution
that these are probably
conservative estimates
of gender bias because
as Anzia and Berry have
very famously shown,
women candidates who actually
enter elections are often
of higher quality than
their male counterparts.
But the important takeaway here is
that even though you have gender parody
for the vast majority of seats,
you see divergence among these
very safe seats on the right
and you might think, well,
how many seats can it be
that are more than R+20?
How big of a problem this is,
actually it's a fairly
substantial problem.
In this current Congress,
about 1/4 of all seats are
in that range where we see that divergence
on the Republican side
and on the Democratic side
you also see a slightly stark pattern
in the opposite direction,
which is that in the
safe Democratic seats,
women are advantaged in their
overall likelihood of winning.
Again, this is conditional
on them entering the primary,
which suggests they may be
of higher quality than
their male challengers.
But as you get into
more competitive seats,
you see that advantage fade away
and you actually see some
evidence of a disadvantage.
This is all to say that from
a purely descriptive account,
it does seem as though women
candidates are advantaged
in the Democratic side in safer seats
and disadvantaged on the
Republican side in safer seats
and that gender gap we showed does seem
to originate partially in safer seats.
But when we add slightly
more rigorous methods
and control for other potential
confounding variables,
does relationship still hold up?
Our answer, at least
as far as we've tested,
it seems to be yes,
that as you get more extreme seats,
the relationship right here,
this our fourth variable
that we have listed,
female times PVI,
that's the interaction effect
between your seat getting safer
in the conservative direction
and a woman candidate.
So these estimates would
suggest in very liberal seats
you should see, which
would have negative PVIs,
you'd see an advantage to being a woman
versus in very conservative seats
you would see a stark disadvantage
which supports the descriptive
finding that we had
in the last slide.
And so now we wanna return back to one
of the important age
alternative hypotheses
that we presented at the beginning
that the conventional
explanation literature holds
which is that, you know,
part of this reason that you
see that stark relationship
between seat safety
and women candidates
could be candidate supply.
And we do find actually evidence
that candidate supply starkly differs
between Democrats and Republicans,
but what's important to us is we also see
that that relationship differs
in terms of seat safety,
that yes, you have that overall decline,
that overall partisan gap.
excuse me, in women who run
but as seats trend towards
safer Republican seats.
less and less women are running
for Congress, which suggests
that this safe seat
explanation cannot be explained
simply by the overall raw
partisan gender gap itself
and because of that, we think that this is
an important domain for future research
and an important way of
understanding why we've gotten
to a point where the dynamics
of Congress are such that,
you know, women Democrats are on the rise
but women Republicans have
seen pretty anemic growth
since the 1980s
and one thing that I just
wanna mention before we move
on to the discussion is a
potential challenge for our case
one would think could
be this most recent set
of elections, 2020.
of course, famously in 2020,
almost every single
Republican who defeated
an incumbent Democrat was a
woman or a candidate of color
but actually when we go through
and look at the the evidence,
we do see further evidence for our theory
in that it was only in
these competitive seats
that the Republican women were able to win
and actually they made very little headway
in the much safer seats.
And so finally, I just
wanna end with a couple
of questions that we wanna
pose out into the ether.
So the first is how should we think
about nonpartisan democratic aims
in the context of redistricting?
Oftentimes the discourse on
gerrymandering is talking
about partisan gerrymandering
and goes to this question of
substantive representation
as Pitkin would put it.
But what we're really talking
about is descriptive representation
and we think that in
line with these findings,
there are also important
descriptive consequences
of safe seats through things
like majority-minority districts,
it's important to think
about these nonpartisan democratic aims
when we're considering something
as partisan as redistricting.
Our second question is
what we presented here
today has been entirely
observational evidence.
So one of the questions that
we have going forward are
are there ways to gather more experimental
or quasi-experimental
evidence on this phenomenon?
And in terms of future research,
just to set that up,
one of the outstanding questions is
how do the few women who do win
in these safe Republican seats
respond to these pressures?
And we're thinking of recent examples
of people like Marjorie
Taylor Greene, for example.
And that brings us to the end
of our prepared presentation.
- Okay.
All right.
Thanks very much for the invitation
to comment on this terrific paper.
This paper examines
one of the most salient
and interesting changes in
Congress over recent decades
and that is the divergence
in the gender composition
of the two parties.
Before 1990, women were slowly
increasing their presence
in both congressional parties,
but after 1990 the two parties diverged.
After the so-called year
of the women in 1992,
women steadily and sharply increased
as a share of the Democratic
Party in Congress.
By contrast, Republicans stopped becoming
more gender diverse for
20 years after 2004.
The first significant
increase in Republican women
just happened with the 2020 elections,
75% jump over the preceding Congress.
So 2020 was unquestionably the
year of the Republican women.
But even after the 2020
boost for Republicans,
the gender discrepancy between
the parties is still wide.
Nearly 40% of congressional
Democrats are women,
as compared to 14% of
congressional Republicans.
This remarkable partisan divergence
in women's representation is
just one among other forms
of sociological divergence
between the parties.
Just for perspective,
I'll highlight a couple
of other cases of social
sorting in Congress.
Religion, I'll focus on
evangelical Christians,
the largest religious group in the US,
constituting just over a
quarter of the population.
In the late 1970s,
evangelicals made up roughly
the same share of both
congressional parties.
But since the 80s, evangelicals
have steadily sorted
out of the Democratic Party
and into the Republican Party.
In recent congresses,
evangelicals make up more
than 1/3 of Republicans,
but less than 5% of Democrats.
Race, another form of social sorting,
as the US population has
become more racially diverse
since the 1960s,
virtually all of that
diversity is represented
in the Democratic Party in Congress.
The Democratic Party
in Congress has grown
steadily more racially
and ethically diverse since the 1970s,
such that 40% of the party
in Congress is currently
Black, Hispanic or Asian.
Meanwhile, the nation's
increasing diversity is
just passing the Republican Party by.
Non-whites have never made up more
than 7% of Republicans in Congress.
So the parties have been sorting
out in sociological terms.
The parties are not just
polarized ideologically,
they're also strongly differentiated
in terms of personal identity.
The paper we're discussing
today helps give us
some new perspective on
factors that are driving
these changes in
congressional composition.
The paper argues that
increases in the number
of safe seats affect the
two parties differently.
Women candidates are more competitive
for safe Democratic Party seats
but less competitive for
safe Republican seats.
Thus, the rise in safe seats
can help shed some light
on what's happening in both parties.
The processes laid out in this paper,
involves multiple steps.
The paper theorizes
that seat safety affects
the decision to run,
who wins in primaries
and who wins in the general election.
Seat safety is thought to affect each
of these steps in the process.
As the authors continue
to work on this paper,
I'd like to see a more careful
breakdown of each step.
Ideally the paper would nail
down the extent to which each
of these factors contributes
to the overall pattern.
It would be great to see
the descriptive statistics,
you know, even without any
controls as a first order matter.
What is the difference between
safe Republican districts
and those that are
marginal for Republicans
in terms of the number of
women running in the primaries,
the likelihood that a
woman wins the primary,
the likelihood that a woman
wins the general election?
And what are the differences between safe
Democratic districts and
those that are marginal
for Democrats on those dimensions
and what are the effect
sizes at each step?
My key recommendation
is that I think it'd be
useful to model the
two parties separately.
The party works with one overall model,
assuming that seat safety
affects female candidates
in both parties in ways
that can be handled
with simple interaction effects
but there are reasons to
think that the effects
of safe seats on candidacy may
differ for the two parties.
I can think of three ways
in which gender might affect
congressional elections
and candidacy.
First, and this is the one that's covered
in most depth in the paper,
women are perceived as more liberal
which is a disadvantage in
safe Republican districts
and an advantage in safe
Democratic districts.
The paper substantially elaborates on that
but there are other reasons
beyond voter perceptions to expect
that safe seats will affect
gender representation.
There's perception and
then there's reality.
Women actually are more liberal,
even among Republicans,
such that there is a smaller pool
of potential female
Republicans considering a run
for office in conservative districts.
This is something Danielle
Thompson finds in her research
on state legislatures.
In an article published
in Legislative Studies Quarterly in 2015,
Thompson finds that there's a dearth
of very conservative
women suitable to make
a competitive bid for Congress
in those strongly Republican districts.
She suggests that the pool
of very conservative women may be growing
but it was still small
as of her study in 2015.
There simply weren't many
quality Republican women
candidates available to run
in conservative districts,
meaning conservative women
who had won elected office
at some level before.
But the same pattern doesn't
exist for the Democratic Party.
Thompson finds that
there's a substantial pool
of moderate women available
in state legislatures able
to make a bid for Congress.
So there's no shortage of
Democratic women available to run
in both moderate and liberal districts.
Third, potential women candidates may have
a differential willingness
to run in the two parties.
Women may look at the Republican Party
in Congress and see
themselves not fitting in,
after all it's an overwhelmingly
male dominated party.
Women may not look at
the congressional GOP
and see a caucus in which they feel likely
that they'll be able to advance
their personal and policy goals.
But women probably don't look
at the Democratic Party similarly.
They're likely to perceive
the Congressional Democratic Caucus
as one where they might fit in
and be able to advance their personal.
That's the safe seat's logic
layout in the paper work
somewhat differently for the two parties.
Democratic Party is reasonably friendly
to women candidates across the board.
Meanwhile, Republicans,
Republican women probably
face a tougher road
where they are more disadvantaged
in conservative districts.
The Democratic women are
disadvantaged in swing districts.
If these kinds of asymmetries exist,
the model used in the paper,
which includes candidates of both parties,
will likely understate the
gender effect for Republicans
and overstate the gender
effect for Democrats.
So I'd like to see a separate
model for the two parties
and does seat safety
have a significant effect
on women's candidacies for both parties?
Second point I'd like to make
is just a note of caution.
I really think the authors are
onto something here with this argument
about how safe seats affect
gender representation
but it's important to
note that there's a limit
to how much this logic can explain.
No doubt there's been a major change
in congressional elections.
There are far more safe seats today
than there were in the late
19th and early 20th centuries.
So here's a figure from
other work by the authors.
As is evident here, it
used to be that more
than 40% of house districts
had elections decided
in the marginal range
and now it's around 10%,
but most of that change
happened a long time ago.
David Mayhew published his famous paper
on the vanishing marginals in 1974.
There has been continued decline
in almost 50 years since,
but the post-1974 change is less
than the change that occurred
in the 50 years before 1974.
Meanwhile, recall that the
gender sorting of the parties
only got underway after 1990.
Before 1990, the share of women
in the two congressional parties was low
but growing in tandem.
It's only after 1990 that
we see the divergence
this paper aims to explain.
The share in this, the change in the share
of safe seats since 1992 is
just a few percentage points.
So it's not a dramatic drop since the 90s.
Given that seat safety hasn't
changed a lot in recent years,
safe seats can only explain
part of the gender sorting
that we've seen since 1990.
Now I'm persuaded that
the authors are really
onto something here.
I suspect that the analysis will hold up
to further robustness checks,
including, as I recommend,
splitting the data by party.
But clearly there's much more to learn
about what's driving
congressional parties apart
along lines of gender and
other sociological factors.
Before I conclude, I'd like
to make one final small point.
The paper often implies that
the decline of competition
in congressional races stems
from partisan gerrymandering.
This linkage is often
suggested in the popular press.
But political scientists
working on this subject have
not been able to document
an effect along these lines.
Here's a representative
finding in the literature
from a 2006 JOP paper by
Abramowitz, Alexander and Gunning,
a paper that's cited in
the paper we're discussing.
Abramowitz and his
coauthors look at the number
of safe and competitive house seats before
and after three recent
rounds of redistricting.
So you can see from the 1980
and then the number of safe seats in 1982,
the number of safe and
competitive seats in 1990
and then after the redistricting
in 1992 and so forth.
And they find that redistricting does
not substantially increase the share
of safe and competitive seat
and they conclude that
at the national level,
redistricting has a negligible impact
on the competitiveness of house seats,
The reason why partisan
gerrymandering does not
have a consistent effect
on electoral competition is
that partisan, the goal of
partisan gerrymandering is not
to maximize seat safety.
The goal of partisan gerrymandering is
to maximize the number of
winnable seats for a party.
Effective gerrymandering
cannot pack too many
of a party's voters into a single district
if it wants to win as
many seats as possible.
Gerrymanderers will often have
to go to their own party's
incumbents to get them to agree
to reduce their cushion of
support so as to spread out more
of their party's voters
into neighboring seats.
The goal of gerrymandering is
to make as many winnable seats
as possible but doing
so will tend to depress
a party's margin of
victory in those districts.
Now, of course, it's also true
that partisan gerrymanders may aim to pack
the opposing party's voters
into as few seats as possible
and doing this obviously makes
for some very safe seats,
like the overwhelmingly Democratic
majority-minority districts.
But gerrymanderers also try to
correct opposing party voters
across a lot of seats
so that the opposing party
doesn't have a very good shot
at winning any of them.
The bottom line is that taken together,
gerrymandering makes some seats safer
and other seats more competitive.
The overall effect of gerrymandering
on competition just tends to wash out.
The rise of seat safety in
Congress has other causes
aside from partisan gerrymandering.
This is not a critical
point for this paper
given that the paper isn't
even about the causes
of safe seats anyway,
but just to steer the authors away
from unnecessary
controversy in the writeup.
So I'll stop there.
- I think that's probably good.
Everyone see that okay?
I only have two slides
and one of them is
actually from the authors.
Well, I'll start off by
just saying thank you
and I really enjoyed this opportunity.
I enjoyed reading the paper.
I think it's a great topic.
It's a really useful data exercise
and they're just some really
interesting stylized facts
that are starting to emerge.
I think the first time
I read through the paper
I felt, you know, like
I was kind of convinced
by what the authors were saying
and wasn't sure what I would have to say
but then on looking at it more carefully,
I started to have a lot more questions
and some of them are about the theory
and some of them are about the empirics
and I'll dive into both of those.
First thing I wanna do is
just to say a little bit
about the ways of framing the paper.
I mean, obviously there's a lot,
you have some some folks among you,
among the authors who know a lot
about the cross national
literature on gender
and representation
and maybe linking this in
with a larger literature
on gender and, you know,
why the US perhaps is,
does this paper help us
understand why the US is
an outlier relative to other countries,
might be an interesting
framing device to consider.
But also in the US literature,
one paper I wanted to
direct your attention
to is by a former student of mine,
Sarah Anzia has a paper with
using a really large data set
from California in which she finds kind
of surprising evidence of a
advantage for female candidates
in a lot of local offices
and finds that there's
something about the nature
of those offices that advantages largest
for school board races
and it gets a little smaller
for city council races
and a little smaller
for mayoral elections,
but she also finds some evidence
that's consistent with yours,
that says that this basically disappears,
this female advantage disappears
the more conservative
the districts become,
which is perhaps not too surprising.
I also think there's a related literature
on local governments in the US,
it might be nice to also think about,
where the story is that one emerging story
and it's one that I've seen
in some data I've looked at,
is that when we look
at at-large districts,
versus when the same
people are represented
in the at-large districts
versus single member district elections,
the at-large districts are
better for female recruitment.
We end up with more
female candidates running
and more female candidates winning
and that probably has something to do
with competition
competitiveness in, you know,
in winner take all, municipal
city council elections are
often very uncompetitive
and there are long-standing
incumbents hanging around
who are, these are people who
a female candidate might be
less inclined to jump
in and try to challenge
than maybe, say a seven
member school board
that has three seats up,
three at-large seats up,
two of which might be
open seats effectively.
That's a very different kind of setting.
So this kind of literature
I think is very related
to what you're doing in
the congressional context.
But I would also encourage you to think,
you know, you've got several authors
and hopefully a lot of time on your hands,
maybe it would be a very
small lift to add state
legislatures to this study.
This Carl Clark dataset
on state legislatures could
be linked with the DIME data
and you could be up and
running doing some similar kind
of analysis with state legislatures
and that would just
give you a larger sample
and some interesting
cross-state heterogeneity
and all of that.
So that would be a nice
thing to think about doing.
So one thing that I thought
Frances might get into,
so she definitely checked the
box on the gerrymandering,
so everything she said about
gerrymandering, I agree with.
I think it's good, it's
good to have, you know,
when people, two people
have the same reaction,
it's good to know what that is.
I don't think this is a paper
about gerrymandering per se.
It's a paper about safe seats
and so you don't need
to make those arguments
about gerrymandering,
but it's something that I
thought might come up is just,
I was surprised not to see incumbency
at least among the control variables,
even more, I thought it might make sense
as something to explore
heterogeneous effects, you know,
are we talking about what happens
when we look at open seats
versus seats where there are
long-standing incumbents?
You know, I think that
incumbency of course is
highly correlated with
the safety of the seats
and a lot of those safe
seats are gonna be ones
when there is an incumbent,
longstanding incumbent running
and some of the people in your data set,
you're looking at some of
these challengers are gonna be
not particularly serious challengers
because it's someone who
everyone knows is gonna
win both the primary and the general
and then there are situations though
even in a very, even in a very safe seat
where a longstanding incumbent steps down
and then there's an open seat.
Surely the dynamics are different in those
and so it'd be useful to take
a look at those separately.
I also wanna think about maybe, of course,
you know, I have to say something
about political geography
and think about how that might matter.
One possible alternative hypothesis is,
you know, is if you just
look at the correlation
between the Cook Index
and population density,
the correlation is like, you know,
it's like .9 or something, it's very high.
This thing, you know,
the main independent variable here
or the interaction term
is very much correlated
with geography in a particular way
so that the safe seats are essentially,
safe Republican seats are very rural,
safe Democratic seats
are almost always urban
with a couple of exceptions
in the Deep South
in majority-minority districts there.
But for the most part,
these competitive districts are
gonna be suburban districts.
And as one of you kinda mentioned,
some of those suburban districts
and some of these, you know,
50/50 districts can actually
end up being, internally, quite polarized.
They can be, if you look
at people's preferences
within the districts,
you end up with this kind
of bi-modal distribution
of political preferences
and so I want to kind of come back
to that thought in a moment,
but what this,
and I just want to get,
I actually want to hear
back from the authors
just how they see the argument working
because this story they want to tell,
as I understand the paper
and the presentation,
is that it's about perceptions
of candidates' platforms,
that people in a sense misperceive
that they believe the female candidates
to be more liberal than
they might actually be.
So there's some kind of
a penalty that applies
to a female candidate who is trying to run
in a conservative district where
she has to really try hard,
she has to kind of do
some things to signal
that she really is conservative
because gender is a cue
that people are using.
And so that's I understand
to be the mechanism,
that it's about perception
of the candidate
but there's this alternative mechanism,
which is just that over time,
Democrats have become more progressive
on gender issues in general
and that something about
that is highly correlated
with their ability, their desire to,
or their, you know,
their bias against female candidates
and so that over time, Democratic voters
in the Democratic districts
have become less biased
against female candidates
but in these relatively rural districts
where people are more
traditional on economic issues
and social issues,
I mean particularly what we
care about here is social issues
and gender issues,
that in those places, people,
things haven't really changed
and that accounts for the
different trajectories,
not really this perception issue.
And so I would encourage you
to think about empirically,
how can we disentangle these things,
these different possible mechanisms?
And one way might be,
if you go in the CCES,
there are questions in
there that ask respondents
what they think the
candidates platforms are
on a seven point scale and on
some different policy issues.
So can you kind of show what you believe
to be going is going on that,
that people are misperceiving
or they're somehow overestimating the
kind of leftist orientation of women
even in the Republican
Party, something like that.
So I guess one of the things I really want
to talk about though that was
as you were doing the presentation,
it's cause you handed it
off from Alex to Akhil,
I felt like there was something important
in the theoretical
argument that was missing.
I didn't quite understand
and also when I read the paper,
what is it about seat safety
and the Cook Index that
you really think matters?
It's this idea, again,
it's about potential misperception
of female candidates'
ideology but I wanna understand
and I think you probably
do have a logic here
that makes sense, but I just,
it's not spelled out
as crisply as I'd like,
what is it that's different
about a safe seat district
than a competitive district?
Or in my language,
what is it that's different
about a rural district
and a suburban district?
And I think what you're saying is
that the primary electorate is different
in some important way
but what exactly is it that is different
about the primary electorate
in the rural district?
Is it just the,
is there like a,
I think it might help a little,
a little toy formal model here,
whether it's something like
a ideological cut point
and then there's this perception,
like is the misperception
larger in those places?
Is like it harder to
credibly commit as a female
to kind of be closer to the
ideological platform preferred
by the median voter?
Is it kind of that kind
of a commitment problem
that's larger?
Or is it just like the number
of voters who are passed
some threshold is larger?
It wasn't clear to me exactly
how their argument worked.
That could have been clearer.
Okay, so on the empirics,
I agreed with a lot.
It just, again, it's
kind of helpful to know
that two people had the same reaction.
I agreed that it would be
nice to just see the data,
just to see, to kinda cascade down
from the the question of
who runs in the primary,
who wins in the primary
and then who wins in the general.
I have exactly that same thing in my notes
but you wanna go through that,
you wanna show us the,
just the broad, descriptive statistics.
That would be great.
But thing I just wanted
to talk about though
that I'm confused by and I
hope you can help me with is
what's going on in figure two?
Because when you went through
it in the presentation,
we just talked about the left-hand panel
and we talked, essentially
all the emphasis is
on that gap on the upper
left-hand panel here between
that dotted line, or the
dashed line and the solid line.
But in the paper we are
told that it's really the,
there's this big difference
between primary elections,
between safe seats
and competitive seats
for Republican women in primary elections.
When I look at that
middle, that middle panel,
I just don't see it.
I see a couple of lines that
are right on top of each other
and I see confidence
intervals that suggest
to me that there's absolutely
no difference at any level
of competitiveness between
a woman's win probability
and a man's win probability
in the Republican primary
and when I go to the right-hand panel,
I look at the general election,
I also don't see any difference.
I see something strange happening
where this data has apparently not wanted
to finish the local polynomial as we move
to the right past like
20 something for females
and so maybe there's a big gap there
but we're not seeing it,
cause I just don't understand how we get
to the overall gap when
we don't see the gap
in the primaries
because the story
in table A2 is that there's
a three percentage point
difference for females
throughout the whole range
and it gets even bigger as
we get into these safe seats.
So it's not showing up in
these local polynomial plots
and I guess my big question is why.
And like, I almost don't think figure two
and table A2 can both be correct.
So I just want to know
what's happening there
but I certainly do see,
I do see a big,
an interesting effect here
for Democratic,
on the Democratic side
between men and women.
So I think I'm probably
running short on time.
I should probably just wrap it up here,
but I think that the big
findings for me is, you know,
I'd like to know whether this, you know,
whether this safe seat thing
for the Republicans is gonna hold up
and how big it is,
but there's, certainly it looks
like there's something
there for the Democrats
but it also looks like, you know,
you have some really powerful evidence
that there's just a big difference
in who runs,
that at the end of the day
that's one of the things
that really hit me
between the eyes,
that there is a big difference
in just candidate recruitment.
And that, those kind of,
those things are kind of working together,
this effect for Democrats in safe seats
which seems to be very, very large
and I'm not,
I'm not sure whether this,
the one on the Republican side,
if you could just help me with figure two,
but the really big thing is
just the difference in who runs
and what.
All right, I think plenty, plenty for us
to talk about there so I'll
turn it back over to you.
- Thanks so much, Jonathan.
So, given the time, I just wanna know,
do the
author presenters wanna make like one
or two quick remarks
and then we can go to questions,
if the audience has questions.
You can also pass if you wanna pass,
it's totally, it's totally your call.
I think these were, you
know, really fantastic
and thought provoking discussions
and that you could easily
spend an hour, I think,
on Frances's remarks and on Jonathan's
but we don't have an hour.
Please go ahead.
- Yeah, I agree with that
so I'm inclined to pass
and if Akhil and Alex want to respond-
- Is that okay, Alex and Akhil,
that we go to the questions?
Thumbs up, excellent.
Okay, Ian, take it away.
I think you have a question,
hands raised,
you're in control.
- Okay, I'm not seeing any hand raised
but I am seeing question
in the chat which says,
Republican states are generally seen
as having strong Christian views
whereas democratic ones are a bit liberal
in terms of Christian views.
Do you think this approach does
shape the opportunity given
to women politically
given that Christianity
generally frowns on women
taking leadership positions
in society?
Anyone want to?
- I think, in general, if
I may just say a few words,
I think it kind of taps into
some of the comments brought
up by the discussants,
which were excellent by the way
and we, you know,
really take everything really well,
especially, you know, with
the gerrymandering comment,
I think that we should really tone it down
because I don't think we believe
that gerrymandering is the key here
but when it comes to Christianity,
I think it's the same question
as some of you had was
whether we're talking
about perceptions related
to gender or the reality that
a liberal candidate could
actually be more liberal
on average than men.
I think for our story, it's
not necessarily the case
that we only care about perception,
it can be both actually,
and the fact that it turns out that
in safer Republican seats
you have rural population is
more traditional gender views
and, you know, it just
disadvantages women in general
who want to, kind of,
you know, run for office in this district,
I don't necessarily think
that it's not in line
with our theory which
there's some kind of alternative.
I think it's pretty much
in line with what we're trying to say
but I totally agree that, you know,
we have to be clear
about what's so special
about safe seats relative
to like a toss up.
- I was gonna say if,
while you're waiting for hands to go up
or questions to be asked,
you should certainly feel free in the gaps
to respond to Frances or
Jonathan, if you would like.
- So one thing, Akhil,
I don't know if you
wanted to pick up on this
but on Frances' point that
the rise of safe seats has
been going on for a long time
and in the period we talking about
it hasn't been that much of an increase,
that's true obviously on one hand,
but on the other hand we do have data
about the partisan difference
in the growth of safe
seats in recent decades.
So do you have any comment
on that as a response
to how much of the heavy
lifting the safe seats can do?
- Yeah, actually I
wanted to say a few words
but I think Akhil might be useful
If you can say a few
words about figure two
and its discrepancy with
the regression tables
since you worked on it more,
but so with regard to
the evidence and safety,
it's still, I think it's true
that if you look just at the
measure of margin of victory,
you don't really see a lot of difference
in the last 20 or 30 years
but I think this measure
in general is very kinda,
not very robust, right?
That's why I feel comfortable
plotting it starting right
after the Civil War in these, in general,
you see this kind of downward trend
but I think if you kind of want to zoom in
and look at the trajectory
within 20 or 30 years,
the thing it's not as easy to
do that because of, you know,
different, the redistricting
and other also changes that have occurred.
I think that's why I think
the Cook Partisan Voting
Index is more robust
as a measure of
ex-anticompetitiveness, right?
So where we look at the
partisan composition
in the two elections prior,
relative to the, you
know, nation in general.
I think if you look at the
Cook Partisan Voting Index
and the trajectory in the last 30 years,
starting in 1990,
we actually we have this evidence
that safe seats have
been on decrease, right?
Pretty, you know, steadily, right,
it's not a huge change
and unfortunately don't
really have a lot of,
I think it's possible to construct it
but we don't really have this data at hand
in regard to Cook PVI prior to 1990
but I believe if we did
have it probably would see
that it's been in decline
since before that as well.
- Okay, Before Akhil takes
up Jonathan's question about
figure two,
I see we do have a question from Gail.
- [Gail] So I just joined
your session a little bit late
but my question is,
because this discussion
has revolved around women
seeking candidacy in safe seats.
I just wanted to get your impression
on the Republican Party's attempt to,
attempt on voter suppression
and gerrymandering.
What impact do you think this
will have on the potential
for women running for
congressional offices?
- So while you think about that,
why don't we get Natalie's
question as well.
- [Natalie] Hello, can you hear me?
Hi.
So I'm new to all of this
and I'm just a high school senior
and I'm not even sure if I'm understanding
all of this right but.
Hello?
- Yeah, you've come back, yeah.
- [Natalie] Hi.
So I'm wondering if the
person who is responsible
for gerrymandering is
the state legislatures
and that means that they are allowed
to increase or decrease safe seats
and competitive seats in like a district.
Does that mean that state legislatures
in theory can manipulate
like female representative in an area?
Yeah, that's my question.
Thank you.
- Yeah. Thank you.
I think presumably in theory
and that's, I think that's one,
actually just look at the paper
and I think that's one of the,
we use the word gerrymandering
twice in the paper
and I think that's one of the kind
of policy suggestions that we have
and that's what discussants
were not really happy about.
So I don't think that, so
in theory it's possible
but I think in practice, you know,
due to kind of partisan
sorting more generally
that people just tend to
live with someone who is
more similar to them
ideology, whether, you know,
deliberately or not, it
happens that, you know,
Republicans live in rural
areas with other Republicans
and Democrats live in urban
areas with other Democrats.
So, you know, the extent
to which you can kind
of manufacture, you know,
safe seats with gerrymandering
I think is very limited
but you can imagine how it is possible
and then thereby affect, you know,
the proportion of female representation.
But I don't think that's a big concern
and I think the same kind
of answer I would have
with regard to voter
suppression, which is,
you know, a very important
issue but I'm not sure how
exactly it would play out with
regard to the gender dynamic
if any of my colleagues would like to add
on that it would be great.
- I would just, I would just add
that whatever the causes
of safe seats are,
to what extent it's self sorting
or what extent it's demography,
to what extent it's gerrymandering
and to what extent it's things
like majority-minority districts,
I don't think to the
extent there's any agency
involved, human agency and planning,
I don't think anybody was intending it
to reduce female representation
the Republican side relative
to the Democratic side.
I think it's an unintended side effect
of whatever has been done
by people, that's my guess.
- Yeah and just to jump in there,
cause I think, again,
taking the comments from our
two discussants very seriously,
I think there is a
question, at least for me,
which is that when we look at things
like majority-minority districts,
we do see examples of
intentional map manipulation,
if you wanna call it that,
to advance descriptive representation.
So I think one of the points
that we were trying to make
with our references to gerrymandering,
which noted should be taken out,
is not necessarily that
that is the cause right now
but that could be a prerogative
that gerrymanderers think about
or people drawing the lines
and I think about this in the context of,
for example, the ACLU right now,
when they're looking at
redistricting for the next year,
they're looking at racial
redistricting, for example.
We don't have a similar concept
for gender redistricting
but perhaps that's something
that in the back of our minds
we should keep in mind,
these unintentional consequences
that Professor Shapiro was talking about.
- Okay, I see that we're coming up to 8:15
which is when we're,
when we're scheduled to finish.
I just wanna ask first the discussants,
are there any last
comments you'd like to make
and then I'll turn to the panelists
and ask if there are any last comments
that any of the panelists
who are presenting
their work would like to make.
- Not from me.
- Okay, thank you, Frances.
- Just keep up the good work.
I look forward to seeing
the next draft of this.
- Terrific.
Thank you, Jonathan.
And our panelist authors,
is there anything else you'd
like to say before we conclude?
- No, thank you for having us.
- It's a pleasure,
absolute pleasure.
Well, let me say, Frances and Jonathan,
you are welcome at any time
you wanna drop in here to Yale
and it reminds us just how
wonderful our colleagues are
out there in the big world
and thank you for such
thoughtful contributions
to the discussion.
And, of course, thank you
to the authors for this,
you know, illuminating
and stimulating paper.
This is a dimension to safe seats
that I think no one contemplated
and it will definitely
affect the way I look
at the patterns of congressional
competition moving forward.
So again, thank you all so much.
With that, let me say thank you very much
everyone for attending.
Our next ISPS Democracy event is
on Tuesday, April 13th, at 4:00 pm,
where we will have a panel
to discuss novel ideas
for elections and
legislative decision-making
and please look for future ISPS events
at our ISPS website.
I'd also like to conclude by thanking all
of the people who worked so
hard to put this event together,
the organizers of this panel,
they include Pam Greene,
Pam Lamonaca, Tory Bilski
and Limor Peer.
With that, again, thank
you all for participating
and attending tonight
and I look forward to
seeing you at future events.
Goodnight.
- Goodnight.